tell me about yourself  everything is fine  how's the situation with your sister  fine  and housework it's fine  you know what word i'm getting a little  tired of hearing from you marty  the f word  [Music]  you're a nice guy i'm not gonna let  anyone use you  therapy works it's empowering  it's liberating i feel like i'm on drugs  i mean i've never taken them before but  i mean i assume this is what drugs feel  like  a little unconventional i don't trust  him go ahead  with your own life leave me alone  marty i have your best interest at heart  but without trust we have  nothing i do trust you i trust you  completely  i do believe you have just had what we  head shrinkers call  a breakthrough jesus  and we're out of time oh  you